مقدم بوتين تعزيه لعائله مؤسس فاجنر وبقيه
ضحايا الحادث ومن بينهم نائب بريجوجن
ديمتري اوتكن وتعهد بوتين بمواصله التحقيق
في الحادث حتى النهايه انذاك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الاسباب
التي ادت الى تاخير سلطات الروسيه الاعلان
عن مصير بريغو ما هي الجهات المستفيده من
غياب بريغوجين ونائبه عن المشهد في روسيا
وكيف نقرا ردود الفعل الروسيه والغربيه
على حادثه
[موسيقى]
يعني اولا هذه هي طريقه بوتين واسلوبه
واكيد هو كان على علم بما حدث ولكن هو
دائما ينتظر النتيجه النهائيه ولكنه كنا
نعلم ذلك منذ الامس عندما اعلنت مؤسسه
الطيران الروسيه روسيا ان وقوي حادثين
وقيل انه هناك اسم
وغيرهم من الاسماء اله قائمه ركاب هذه
الطائره اعتقد ومن المهم جدا ان نتذكر ان
وهو المؤسس الاخر كان على الرحله بالتالي
في انفجار واحد قاموا بالقضاء على فيغنار
يقال ان الانتقام افضل ياتي باردا بعد
شهرين من المحاوله الانقلاب التي قادها
وتحركه نحو موسكو والكثير شك ان هذا الامر
سيحصل لكن اذا كانت فقط مساله بالتالي
الكثير بتفاجاوا كيف التقى بريكوجين مع
بوتين لشرب الشاي لركنه ربما كان طريقه
بوتين من اجل استعاده السيطره على فيغنر
غير ناتج ان ان الصاروخ او اسقاط لم يكن
هناك الاسقاط
اعصابت اصيبت هذه الطائره بصاروخ لم تكن
الشظايا مثل هذه القطع الكبيره التي وقع
وزنا على الارجح كانت هناك
عمليه التي نفضتها الجحا محنيه جدا عن
طريقه التوجير
احدى الفرضيات كانت انه في اخر
صندوق او كرتونه شامبوانيا الى الى
الطائره في اخر اللقطه قبل اقلالها وربما
كانت المتفجرات في هواء هذا على فكره
الاسلوب الذي كان متبع في اختي
ارسكي
وغيرهم من الاشخاص
شخصيات البارزه في روسيا ايضا تحذير لكل
مناوئ لبوتين وروسيا هذه رساله مفادها
عليكم ان لا تحاولوا ان تقوموا باي شيء
ضدها لانكم ستواجهون مصيرا مؤلما
[موسيقى]
تلعب دورا مهما في الدول التي
التجات قياداتها الا هذه المجموعه
العسكريه الى هذه الشركه ودائما هناك
مصران مسار الخارجيه الروسيه هو المسار
السياسي وهناك المسار مسار شركه وغيرها من
الشركات العسكريه الضربه ضد
ذاتها الضربه ضد النفوس الروسي في افريقيا
لان تواجد هذه الشركه العسكريه في بعض
الدول في شمال افريقيا خاصه
لديه الدور وهو لابد من ان ناخذ في اين
الاعتبار عند الدراسه تحليل التحليليه
ووضع سينيوريرات مستقبليه لانه
بالفعل الشركه دورا فيما يتعلق الخدمات
الامنيه اعتقد ان بوتين وايضا مساعدوه
حاولوا ان يقوموا بتضليل الاشخاص الذين
يدونون له بالولاء لانهم يريدون ان يعملوا
مع الجيش الروسي ومع بوتين لان فاجنر يتم
اعتبارهم على انهم وحده منفصله بالتالي
سنه ربما ظهورا للقاده المستقبلين لقياده
فاجنر علينا ان ننتظر لنرى ذلك ونرى اذا
ما كان جنود واعضاء سيصدقون هذا الامر
مشكله اللي كانت
هي كانت المشكله الاشكاليه مع
البيروقراطيه العسكريه كما ان كان يطلق
عليها وعلى راسها الوزير شويغو ورئيس هيئه
الاركان كراسي هي كانت المشكله وتم حل هذه
المشكله
بوساده الرئيس لوكاشينكا وطبعا
بالتنسيق مع بوتين نوسه
[موسيقى]
خطر ان نقوم باي تنبؤ في هذا المجال لكنني
ساقول انه خلال الشهرين الذي التي مضت
اعتقد انه حاول ان يسيطر نقودا حول ان
يسيطر على هذا الامر سيستمر واعتقد ان هذا
امر اساسي من اجل الحفاظ على تاثير روسيا
في افريقيا لا اعتقد انه سيكون له تاثير
كبير على الحرب فاغنار ستستمر بارسال
القوه تعتقد ان كان يعتبر
كان قد قام باشياء مروعه في فتره حياتي
واعتقد ان الناس في اوكرانيا يشعرون
بالراحه لكنهم بالتاكيد سيكون هناك شخص
اخر يحل محل بالتالي الحرب ستستمر في
اوكرانيا